when I was seven I wanted to be an
actress and I wanted to live my dream
and when I was 11 I had a casting
director tell me that I wasn't strong
enough to carry my own show
and
I'm sure all of you have been told that
you don't have what it takes and that
you may not be good enough and you don't
have enough people supporting you and
you're being told all of these things
and deep down it's all you want to do
you want to be a part of something great
you want to make something great and it
does more than knock the wind out of you
it crushes you when people try to tell
you that you're not good enough
and it almost did for me but there was
my mom next to me stronger than ever and
she said the most important thing is to
always trust in myself if I have if I'm
doing something because I love it I
should do it because I love it and I
believe I can do it
so she told me to keep going she told me
and she taught me to turn the other
cheek and let the critics be critics and
let us just trust ourselves
so for me two years later I got my own
show and the first thought the first
thought wasn't oh man that girl when I
was 11 said I wouldn't carry my own show
and I did I mean I thought about that
for a little bit but I thought about
what my mom said my mom was like you
have to trust yourself and I realized if
I didn't believe that I could do it
I wouldn't be able to be here and I have
I'm gonna I'm gonna say I live a very
blessed life I have
so much to be thankful for and a lot of
you are a big part of inspiring me
because I don't think you get it and
maybe you're not told enough
but you inspire me to be better
and we should Inspire each other to be
better I'm surrounded by people who are
supposed to guide me and some of them
have and others haven't
they pressure me there's so much
pressure you gotta be sexy you gotta be
cute you gotta be nice you gotta be all
these things
[Applause]
and I'm sure you can all relate you all
have pressure that you have to deal with
every day I'm sure with school with work
with friends with parents with family
with parents I know sometimes of mine
they tell me what to wear how to look
what I should say how I should be until
recently I had given into that pressure
I lost sight of who I was
I listened to opinions of people
and I tried to change who I am because I
thought that others would accept me for
it
and I realized I don't know how to be
anything but myself
important thing is that we learn and we
continue to learn from each other
please stay true to yourself please just
remain who you are and know that we have
each other's back I'd be lying if I said
that I've never tried to make myself
better by giving in because I have but
I've learned from my actions
and for all the things I've done I'm
proudest of that I've learned from my
mistakes
I want you to know what it's like that I
know what it's like figuring out what
types of friends you have you are who
you surround yourself with
so I just want to say I hope I can
Inspire each and every one of you to
just trust yourselves and to love and to
be loved I was driving myself crazy
first off there was a million things
that I didn't want to see yeah and I
would see them over and over and over
again then I'm comparing then I'm
looking at these people and I'm like how
do they it just it's all the things that
people say right it's nothing new it's
that you usually sometimes feel like
you have fomo everyone's life looks
amazing and that happens to me too I'm
like well what am I not like I'm missing
the plot here like right some things how
come it's so fun for everyone else then
it just started getting dark there were
accounts that were
dissecting me
down to my body to my face to my
features
choices I've made telling stories and it
drove me crazy because I honestly just
wanted to be like none of you you even
know what you're talking about and it
just destroyed me so I stopped and I
tell every single person everything
changed
and I'm also I'm also I I'm living in
that time where there's a specific look
that's going on within females so that
would get in my head as well you know
yeah I do look young so there's nothing
I can do about that of course I am 27
but
sometimes I'm like oh I look like a baby
which is stupid and I don't fit into
that look
which isn't a bad thing and it's not bad
that that's what people enjoy and like
it's whatever makes you feel comfortable
of course but like when I was out of
social media I was so much happier with
with just me myself how I worked and
that helped a lot there's a huge part of
me that didn't get a chance to develop
my identity in a normal setting so when
I was working with Disney it was the
best time of my life and I had a great
time I have nothing but good things to
say but it was a bit more controlled
there were certain things that I was you
know kind of uh not had to do and not
maybe go into like figuring out what my
sound would be so I um I've constantly
been trying to make my music better and
better because you know I I know that
people may not think I'm the greatest
singer but I just worked my ass off and
I love I really love writing and
creating and creating Melodies and
growing and I I felt like this was my
chance to say all the things that I
wanted to say in in that way
when people look at me
they don't see a 22 year old figuring it
out as she goes they see what they want
to see and that comes with a lot of
expectations I know what it's like to be
judged and to be put down
I know what it's like to have other
people form opinions of you without even
knowing you
trying to dim your life I know what you
guys go through because I go through it
every single day but I don't let it get
to me it's entirely normal to get pulled
off course and just to get in my mind
and and let that inside and distract me
from who I am
but if I actually did that it would
drive me crazy I want to say you are not
defined by an Instagram photo by a like
by a comment that does not define you
I want you guys to know that the trick
is is to focus on the love and what I
want you guys to do every rude comment
you get every person that tries to hurt
you personally or through the internet I
want you to forgive them just forgive
them because they don't even know they
have no idea
there is so much love in this world and
in this Stadium do not limit yourself
because of what others expect we all
deserve more than we think and in the
end nobody remembers those those haters
the comments nobody remembers them
they're just background noise when it's
over nothing defines you but what you
leave behind and what lives you touch on
the way it's a lesson that I'm still
trying to learn but I'm so grateful for
what I have and I am ready for what
comes next in my life and if you take
just one thing from today let it be this
I want you guys to believe in yourselves
because I believe in you and you guys
need to believe in each other